le confinement partiel et partial ils
touchent surtout les commerces voilà dit
non essentiels c'est vous avez été
classé nsa en tant qu'esthéticienne
parmi les commerçants essentielle est-ce
que vous êtes dans une situation
comparable à celle des restaurants par
exemple ou est-ce que c'est plus
spécifiques - déjà c'est plus spécifique
est d'autant plus que je veux dire
quelque chose qui est très important
c'est que nous dans nos métiers en fait
ce qui n'a pas été aussi souligner c'est
que quand on a été continu et là au
deuxième confinement les esthéticiennes
à domicile elles ont continué à
pratiquer donc déjà ça c'est intolérable
comme pour les coiffeurs je suppose
qu'il se ralliera ce que je dis puisque
1 or prennent notre clientèle déjà dû
donc c'est même pas que de l'argent
qu'on perd là c'est carrément notre
clientèle qu'on est en train de perdre
oui en plus de ça on n'a pas les aides
on n'a pas été reconnue parce que moi je
me suis connecté tout de suite sur le
formulaire
il ya écrit entretien corporel et
entretien corporel sakho répond ça
correspond pas aux métiers de
l'esthétique
donc j'en bénéficie pas je ne sais pas
de quel clash fait partie alors on
m'annonce ce soir j'apprends ce soir que
c'est à partir du 20 novembre
ok parfait duo à partir du 20 novembre
je vais avoir deux mille euros puisque
c'est selon mon chiffre d'affaires du
mois de novembre de l'année dernière
sauf que derrière ça deux mille euros en
novembre
en décembre c'est quoi je suis pas sûr
de réouvrir en descend donc je suis pas
sûr de vivre
en janvier on me refais fermée jusqu'en
février et après comment ça se passe la
suite
et quelle est la suite en fait parce que
c'est bien beau d'annoncer aujourd'hui
mais on dira plus de difficultés yalin
sharing oui voilà qu'on joue franc jeu
annoncé nous c'est six mois il y en a
pour six mois fin de l'histoire
tu te débrouilles à 2000 euros par mois
pendant six mois mais c'est pas la peine
d'envoyer des dix mythes des 15
milliards des 10000 euros tout de suite
on n'en veut pas en fait dit nous on n'a
nulle et et charges les charges
annulation et après essaye de vivre
matois pourtant quotidien ta vie ta vie
de famille
un cap une direction de sortie des
réponses et des réponses mais clairement
clairement qu'on nous dise pas utilise
le click and collect aujourd'hui la
chambre des métiers m'appelle et me dit
je clique un collecte je suis au lit
autant dire que je n'ai pas acheter de
produits de beauté
là c'était difficile tous les mois d'été
donc j'ai rien acheté en trésorerie
donc qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je
vende mais les trois rouges à lèvres là
qui me reste dans mon institut mais il
ya eu un certain dans certains coins de
france dans certaines villes il ya eu un
mouvement de désobéissance civile est ce
que vous avez oui vous avez ouvert
clandestinement votre votre tablette
donc j'ai ouvert clandestinement donc
voilà fais moi
malheureusement j'ai du ccma destiny t
parce que bon déjà dit je tiens à dire
que là quelles conditions vous avez été
obligé qu'est ce qui se passe dans ces
cas-là il ya khouya qui visitent la
gendarmerie voilà voilà oui c'est du
sérieux mais comment c'était très
sérieux
ensuite je tiens à dire que déjà je suis
tout seul dans mon institut de beauté
que l'ama principale activité ma source
de revenu c'est mes prestations et non
pas la vente que j'utilise des spatules
jetables de la cire jetables du papier
jetables je suis tout jetable
je ne recyclent rien du tout donc après
c'est un bon départ à l'écologie et là
c'est pas le mieux mais un autre de
bornes c'est un autre débat mais en tout
cas tout est jetable chez moi donc j'ai
pas de salarié je prends toutes les
précautions
c'est je veux pas être dans l'illégalité
maintenant j'ai été poussé à le faire
parce que le mercredi on nous apprend
que qu'on doit fermer jeudi soir en une
journée je suis tout seul j'ai pas
d'employer toutes mes clientes mois puis
le mercredi soir jusqu'à 22h30 je
réponde à mes clientes pour leur dire je
vous cale de main jeu vocal demain je
cale demain j'ai calé tout le monde donc
je m'organise pour faire garder mes
enfants
et en plus je dois calais toute ma
clientèle sur un mois en une journée
non mais c'est vrai qu'on pense pas sa
mémoire attendait il n'ya pas
d'anticipations de l'état moi je peux
pas anticiper pour eux donc je fais
comment
vendredi jean prend encore un peu samedi
jean prend encore un peu parce qu'elle
me dise oui mais attends là après je te
vois pas pendant un mois ou deux mois
non mais la zone nombre de ce
confinement c'est quand même le sort
fait aux commerces indépendants dit une
donnée essentielle il ya quelque chose
qui ne va pas quand on entend votre
témoignage
il ya quelque chose qui ne va pas et
commencent à l'impression que le
confinement qui doit être quelque chose
de général en fait un confinement en
slalom entre les cas particuliers donc
soit au total ment sont confiantes
personne mais l'entre-deux ne peut pas
marcher il n'y a que des exceptions et à
côté de collection vous avez les
mathématiques savent très bien que les
cas particuliers ne sont plus des cas
exceptionnels et qu'on peut pas faire de
théorie à partir d'eux